hello welcome back to GameSpot's the
continuing coverage of games come 2014
I'm done here is James there route
extender mode it's almost it's well I
guess the business days are like kind of
done more seats around than they were
before it's wonderful and you saw a
video game today a game what a titles so
generic
I had to write on the inside of my
wrists to like remember it it's called
shadow realms it's Bioware's for me one
thing
so Bioware Austin it's kind of making a
lil quiet tho they did the Old Republic
and then it was just nothing so then
they came out at EA's little digital
press conference thing with shadow
realms so v1 it's not evolved and you
get to kind of so that's for kind of
everyday heroes and then there's some
kind of rift between this kind of world
where magics been allowed to flourish
and then our world we have on technology
Sarah Miller Rafe gets punches punched
through and all of these regular Joe's
get magic powers and so you can mix up
with like weapons and magic but then
when you go into this other realm
there's obviously a guy kind of wants to
mess stuff up a bit though the Shadow
Lord he was super powerful he can you
know set the environments he can lay
traps and bombs and bring in other like
animals and beasts and then possess them
so I played a bit yeah
I've got to say it's so much fun really
the thing is I was absolutely terrified
I played as The Shadow Lord and I was
like well I'm just gonna die so the
shadow world can't die first of all
amazing are you controlling this like
third-person isometric what is it yeah
so you can control it so whenever I use
the shadow load if you're just shadow
loading around yeah as you did they
can't see okay and you can just lay
spike traps and bombs and every time you
reach a kind of safe room you get like
in another power and other ability
filled it up slowly that way and you can
possess any kind of minions that pop up
and you can summon beast so then you can
possess that another really cool one I
really love
when you basically become a clone of one
of the heroes okay oh and they don't
know it's you yeah and so you can just
like I'm fighting with you guys and then
backstab and you do loads of damage
right so your job is to basically stop
them getting to the final room defeat
the final boss who you can possess as
well which is so fun so much fun but
then it's Bioware so there's gonna be
this overarching episodic storyline it's
gonna be romancing single player
progression or really yeah gonna be done
episodically so each episode might end
like a cliffhanger there's yeah
single-player stuff you can do and then
you can kind of round up some friends to
be like hey what take on the
shadowlord's her along with the levels
taking is it something like a 20 minute
skirmish stuff 15 minutes which is
pretty a pretty decent chunk and I love
that I mean it's going into alpha in a
within about two months people are
finding up for now it's gonna really
late next year
really all right well there you go
Color Me excited to do / - joohyuk nano
come on
think of a better name for right now I'm
spa chat alone no it's like she's got a
better yeah
shut up Lawrence why why get it done
Gamescom 2014
you